I Am Legend had a pretty final ending
for Will Smith's character and yet he's
coming back for the sequel here's why
this isn't as crazy as it seems in a
matter of weeks Will Smith has been
confirmed for not one but two sequels to
the most notable films in his career
besides for uniting with Martin Lawrence
for a fourth Bad Boys film it was
announced this week that Smith would be
returning to the world of I Am Legend
only this time we'll have some backup
handled once again by director Francis
Lawrence who Helms the first film back
in 2007 the sequel will see Smith
fighting off the end of the world
alongside Creed 3 star and director
Michael B Jordan okay so you're probably
remembering the fact that Smith's
character Robert Neville blew himself up
at the end of the first film
Neville applied the last nail to his
coffin personally to provide a cure for
Humanity and put an end to those pasty
same-looking CGI darkseekers becoming a
legend in his own right you know hence
the name thanks to I am Legend's
Infamous alternate ending however
Neville is back in Action so what's
happened in the unused scene that
allowed this to happen available to
anyone who owns a DVD player the
original home release of I Am Legend
came with an alternate ending that is
now being slipped back into the official
Canon timeline this secret and slightly
more upbeat finale saw Neville trade
with the alpha male darkseeker in
exchange for his mate on whom Neville
has been experimenting in order to find
a cure for the disease
time
after the creature flees with his group
Neville is shocked to realize that the
dark Seekers are intelligent and capable
of Love Neville who has been capturing
and testing darkseekers has become a
legend in the eyes of the infected who
fear and loathe him as a monster from
there Neville and Alice braga's
character Anna head to Vermont hoping to
find other human survivors all's well
that ends well basically with this
alternate exit back on the board however
what could it mean for the newly planned
Sequel and what part does Michael B
Jordan have to play in it the alternate
I Am Legend ending leaves many gaps that
the new installment will need to fill
for one even after finding a cure
Neville's perspective has changed having
accepted that this new subspecies of
humans don't want to be cured given that
I am Legend 2 is set years after the
first film this idea could cause some
friction with other human survivors
Jordan's character included it would
certainly make for a welcome change of
pace to see two survivors facing off in
a battle of post-apocalyptic ideology
that said seeing these two stars work
together side by side would be a treat
in itself still if they really want to
throw out a curveball the movie could do
with the original dark Seekers and have
Jordan be a new breed of monster
squaring off against Smith's season
Survivor who knows of course while I Am
Legend wasn't a huge success the first
time around the box office is currently
thriving by way of Legacy sequels so
there's a chance if done right but this
could enjoy the same levels of hype as
say top gun Maverick only with fewer
Jets and more CGI vampires however I am
Legend 2 turns out though it's nice to
see The Originals first and arguably
Superior ending finally getting the
official recognition that it deserves
foreign